foreign
it's impossible to not hear you just
breathing super loudly okay fine I will
hold my breath for three minutes all
right let's go okay let's go right now
just clock up right here almost there
and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can plank keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time Lots yeah okay
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do